[Music]
hi guys it's quinn here as always if you
appreciate my content consider hitting
the like button so that the youtube
algorithm actually notices me
so today we're here to talk about the
new foundation trailer that came out a
few days ago i wasn't going to talk
about it at first but then i decided you
know there actually is something to say
about this trailer
now
we don't know exactly how much of this
trailer
is representing the whole show
right so the show is 10 episodes for
this first season so is this trailer the
entire plot for the whole first season
or is it just the beginning is my main
question because in the trailer we don't
really see the formation of the
foundation so
in the foundation book by isaac asimov
if you don't know
many many decades jump in between the
chapters of the book it's about the
reformation of a galactic civilization
after the fall of one galactic
civilization but from looking at this
trailer it seems to be about like it's
still in the psycho-historians phase of
the book which is the first chapter
which is just about the establishment in
the beginning before the foundation has
even started it's just about the
beginning of it so i wonder if this
entire first season is going to be in
this era i can't really imagine 10
episodes on that which leads me to think
that what's actually happening is that
the first three episodes are going to be
in this era the psycho historians era
and also the fact that apple tv is going
to release the first three episodes
simultaneously on september the 24th
makes me think that maybe it's just the
psycho historians
that will be those first three episodes
because i really really can't see
stretching out that first phase of the
story over 10 episodes it would make a
lot more sense you give us these first
three episodes and then we jump to the
next part of the story and that would be
really really exciting but i don't know
if this show actually has the balls to
do it i don't know if like
most modern shows don't have the balls
to like drop all the characters and then
start over with new characters after a
few episodes most shows would not do
that so it remains to be seen the
trailer itself looks so high quality
that's one thing that i've said that
really excited me about the first
trailer like the high qualitiness of it
high qualitiness i don't know if that's
actual english but it looks really
really good the cgi looks really really
good the sets look really good the
costumes look really good it's very very
very high budget that of course isn't
everything but what it does show is that
there is a lot of investment behind this
show it does not look cheap it does not
look like something that was just kind
of slapped together and one thing that i
noticed about the trailer too is that
this one's really
kind of focusing in on harry selden as
kind of the shepherd of humanity's
future there's even a part in the
trailer where you see him caress a
younger character's face almost like a
father figure
which is interesting because you know in
those foundation books harry seldon does
kind of act like a father to the
foundation he like is the only character
that shows up again and again and again
because he's been preserved in
holographic recordings that um appear at
certain times not without spoiling too
much but it also looks like from looking
at the trailer that these characters are
also given giving emphasized roles it
looks like there's new characters like
this triple emperor person
um is not from the book i'm not sure
what's going on with that so it looks
like they're setting up some new things
because it is a tv show and for a modern
tv show you do have to like the
characters have to be real and they have
to be people and we have to be able to
relate with characters to keep people
engaged with the modern tv show as
opposed to the book which really is just
about the formation of an empire over
time and it's not about any one given
character really um but that is a style
that is
more easily done in a book as opposed to
a tv show but there is a way that that
can be adapted i think um
but is it something that i think most
people would watch
right off the bat and would immediately
be interested in i don't know so maybe
apple is getting us in with this trailer
like hey this is it is and they're not
really telling people that they're going
to do that jump which to me is exciting
i think i think it's awesome that like
they'd shock us in episode four and it's
like okay it's the next phase of the
book and it's like all those people are
dead and now we're seeing how the
foundation evolves from this point on if
they actually had to call to do that i'd
be really really excited but it remains
to be seen like i said the show looks
visually very very impressive i think
they didn't they did not cheap out on it
but as far as the show being an accurate
representation of asimov's work
um obviously things have been changed um
but
whether or not it respects the source
material remains to be seen and whether
or not the writing in the show is
actually good remains to be seen because
obviously we could turn on the show in
september and it's just got like
terrible dialogue and bad acting it
could be it could be full of all the
things that made the last few seasons of
game of thrones like so terrible like
it's like pretty to look at yes really
really great cgi and costumes and set
designs and stuff
but the acting and the plot is like down
the drain so that remains to be seen and
i will review this show when it comes
out it's exciting that i'll have three
episodes to review um immediately so
that that'll give me like a view like a
good picture of what this show is gonna
be like and i think that's very bold of
them as well that shows me that they
have a lot to say
and they want people to kind of glimpse
the story for what it is
um before they like give up because a
lot of times like you'll have like a
premiere of something you have people
watching the first episode but then they
won't come back the next week but with
something like foundation which is very
much about the long view of history
maybe three episodes is appropriate to
get people hooked it's more like a long
movie um it's very very very exciting
like i always say um
i'm really happy that classic science
fiction is being adapted right now we
have found a foundation television show
that i never dreamed that they would
make and we've got this awesome
dinnerville no dune movie that's coming
up that i never dreamed would look this
good either so it's just very exciting
for me as someone that loves these books
and hopefully hyperion is next i think
that is a
book series that is so ready to be made
into a tv show it lends itself to the tv
show like format i think uh better than
a lot of other sci-fi stuff does
but not to ramble on for too long if you
want to see the foundation trailer link
in the description
please leave a like and subscribe for
more science fiction lore content thank
you guys so much peace out
you